welcome to the program joining you from
very very sunny very hot Northampton
Massachusetts today we have not only
indictments now but also jailings of
Trump staff in the Trump Russia
investigation and it's not going away
and it's not ending anytime soon former
Trump campaign manager Paul Manafort has
been sent to jail and Paul Manafort you
might recall was previously indicted
released on bail I told you last week he
was rien died today Stamper in charges
he was contacting people apparently via
text voice and also encrypted message
and trying to influence what they were
going to be telling investigators and he
has been charged and a judge has now
sent him to jail judge Amy Berman
Jackson said quote this isn't middle
school I can't take away his cell phone
if I tell him not to call 56 witnesses
will he call the 57th and he is now in
jail and we're gonna get to Donald
Trump's reaction in a moment but I do
want to remind you that all along we
were told nothing will ever come of this
right there's nothing to look into there
will be no charges
there will be no indictments there will
be certainly nobody going to jail or to
prison and of course pretrial detention
which is what Paul Manafort finds
himself in at this point is not prison
in the sense of a sentence but it is
somebody being held in jail because they
simply weren't able to just behave like
an adult
and follow simple instructions from the
judge which include don't start
contacting witnesses and potential
witnesses and influencing their
testimony which is exactly what he did
Trump immediately both defending
metaphor with logical fallacies but also
part of the idea is to distance from
mana for and we'll get to that in a
little bit Donald Trump saying it's
wrong to send Paul mana for its jail
because he has worked for other
presidents and actually in one tweet
which I'm going to show you Donald Trump
it's amazing I know that now there's 280
characters in in a tweet instead of 140
Trump has four
glaring errors including multiple
logical fallacies in just one tweet
Trump tweeting wow what a tough sentence
for Paul Manafort who has represented
Ronald Reagan Bob Dole and many other
top political people and campaigns
didn't no mana for was the head of the
mob and what about and he says what
about Comey
and crooked Hillary and all of the
others very unfair so let's break this
down piece by piece because it's
actually in a sense it's remarkable that
he's able to insert so much nonsense
into one tweet first of all Trump says
that this is a sentence for Paul
Manafort mana Ford hasn't been sentenced
to anything right mana Ford is being
held pretrial because of his behavior
and a judge's decision to call this a
sentence confirms I was going to say
demonstrates but it actually confirms
the fundamental total lack of
understanding of the American justice
system that Donald Trump has secondly
Trump says that this is wrong to do to
Paul Manafort because manna for worked
for Ronald Reagan that's an ad hominem
genetic fallacy and you might think well
David ad hominem is when you insult
someone instead of dealing with the
argument ad hominem just means to the
man right it means that it's it could be
a positive or negative statement about
an individual in this case it happens to
be positive but it's the same fallacy as
saying oxygen is bad because Hitler
breathed oxygen right that it's kind of
a silly example here it's manna fort is
good and too good for jail because he
once worked for Ronald Reagan and of
course that's totally fallacious
logically next logical fallacy is Trump
says I didn't know manna fort was the
head of the mob that is a straw man
fallacy right rather than saying why
it's wrong to send manna fort to jail
for the actual reasons manna Ford is
being sent to jail Trump is defending
manna fort by saying this guy's not a
mob boss which is not an argument
anybody made for sending pom anaphoric
to jail
and then lastly logical fallacy number
three and this one tweet Trump says what
about come--and crew
hillarie right the idea is why is mana
fort being held pretrial if neither
james comey nor hillary clinton are in
jail nor prism prison and that's classic
what about ism right james comey and
hillary clinton haven't been indicted
for anything and in any case even if
they had been indicted that wouldn't
have any bearing on whether the right
decision for Paul Manafort is to hold
him pretrial because he's now accused in
a second series of indictments of
tampering with witnesses and it's also
just a really Doug dumb argument in this
case because in general people who
haven't been charged with crimes don't
get sent to jail right like that's just
it's kind of a dumb argument that
doesn't even make sense at its face and
meanwhile so that on the one hand
there's this ludicrous and laughable
defense of Paul Manafort who's now in
jail at the same time much like with
Michael Cohen the Trump attempt to
distance the campaign from their own
campaign chairman continue Trump said
during this bizarre pseudo press
conference outside of the White House
that quote manna fort has nothing to do
with our campaign there's two analyses
there one is that trumps using the
present tense right when he says manna
Ford has nothing to do with our campaign
that's technically true because manna
Ford is not currently involved with
Trump's re-election campaign he's in
jail so obviously he's not currently
involved with Trump's campaign but it's
a distortion right because manna fort
was Trump's campaign chairman Menna fort
ran Donald Trump's delegate strategy
which was a big piece of how he ended up
winning by initially starting to pick up
delegates here and there during the
Republican primary and don't forget that
when it comes to Russia manna fort was
the guy who was pushing the Republican
Party to harden their stance against
Ukraine and to soften their stance on
Russia which they did right before the
the Republican National Convention in
summer of 2016 so the distancing is
totally transparent and bogus and a
really funny side note most media
outlets when Paul Manafort was sent to
jail correctly reported the headline
which is Paul Manafort
to jail that that's correct right Paul
Manafort jailed whatever you whatever
phrasing you want to use for at least a
while Fox News was reporting this as
Manafort pleads not guilty to witness
tampering which is accurate but it is
not at all the most relevant and
newsworthy part of the story then
relevant and newsworthy part is not only
has this guy been adult indicted
multiple times he can't even keep it
together enough while out on bail to
stay out of jail
and the next thing i want to talk with
you about is the insanity of the
reactions to Paul Manafort being sent to
jail including by Alan Dershowitz who
has completely jumped the shark over the
last year and a half